america's re-education camps this is a
real clear policy story we rightly
criticize and condemn china for sending
more than one million
yogurts muslims to
uh
educate re-education camps but we have
our own milder version of re-education
camps that indoctrinate all for a
supposed good evolved cause we call our
re-education camps public schools okay
here's one example of it for evanston
right outside of chicago of what first
and second graders are now taught in
school this is not a one-off or a rogue
teacher this is the curriculum endorsed
by the superintendent and school board
this is curriculum this is the
curriculum for teaching seven-year-olds
it covers more than seven thousand
kitten gardeners through eighth grade
attending 15 school when at what
evanston and school across the country
are doing is unequivocally misguided it
is dangerous it is divisive it hinders
not help
uh inclusion healing progress community
and support what what do you say about
these
re-education camps you had some thoughts
yesterday i'd love the audience to hear
it
you know guys look you know i
i know about the re-education camps
right my uncles was part of the
re-education camps i interviewed my
uncle growing up
um
it's about changing your mind
right it's about brainwashing you to a
whatever
ideology they're trying to
so
yes i do believe in the re-education
camps is our schools right they're
targeting our youth and they're
targeting our youth with uh the critical
race theories right blaming a certain
race for for everything what you think
is going to happen man
what do you think when these kids grow
up what do you think you think it's
going to be a more racist world or you
think it's going to be a more civilized
world when we're introducing critical
race theories into
you know education well critical theory
comes from the frankfurt school it's
it's marxist in its origins and it's
meant to be divisive right it's it's an
actual you talked about modern warfare
this is psychological warfare this is
propaganda this is indoctrinating an
entire generation to believing that
there are good and evil based on
immutable characteristics things that
you cannot change about yourself you
were born as one of the good guys or
you're born one of the bad guys and the
only way to help the good guys if you're
a bad guy is to completely seed any
personal agency yeah so
um anybody who doesn't know about the
frankfurt school ain't nobody that
doesn't know about critical race theory
i i really really really encourage you
to start reading up as much as you
possibly can and if you want to see what
indoctrination looks like
uh look up um what was it kai i sent you
my china my life as a communist party
member i can't it's from five years ago
i can't believe this is up uh there's
two different videos it's my life as a
communist party member look at like two
minutes in and then the other one is uh
i don't want free media and it's actual
chinese communist members talking about
why you don't need free media and you
know why life without free thought is
actually beneficial to the
to the collective it's fascinating
fascinating to watch if you guys have
ever seen this stuff um
and it's
isn't it interesting though that they
want public school in our country that
they want public school to essentially
extend into people's mid-twenties now
public school free college free free
community college so four years let's
talk about those free colleges china
funds our major universities they've
been doing this for a while so along
with them funding our major universities
don't you think they inject an idea into
these
universities with the professors
because they're funding it right so
they're they're funding the curriculum
so they have a say in this so think
about it like
70s right so let's say the the uh the
post-vietnam war hippie era right think
about that so now they're injecting a
communist ideology where where are these
youth now there are politicians there
are leaders in america john kerry right
so now they have this communist ideology
who has embedded them in college now
we're just embedding in in in elementary
school
at a at a very vulnerable state in their
subconscious mind because they're going
to take things in the way it is they
don't have that analytical mind to
decide what is right or wrong yet bill
de blasio's parents
fought and funded the sandinistas in
nicaragua
and then this guy became mayor of new
york city
his parents helped over he his parents
helped finance and you know like they
were part of the consider like a che
guevara type for the the communist
sandinistas overthrowing nicaragua now
this guy you know ran the the most
important city in america i mean it's
not what sound what you're saying to
people
sounds like crazy right-wing conspiracy
theory they're like this is insane this
is the third nobody has a 30-year plan
there's a 30-year plan there's a
fifth-year plan it's playing out in
front of people and they they just
refuse at any point to connect very
obvious dots you know and it becomes
incredibly frustrating from the other
side because at some point like you you
and i patrick is the same way you have
natural precluding patrick always talks
about being a synergist bring people
together make the argument i'm kind of
at the point where i you know what
sink or swim
you know the information's out there
read it or don't i don't care i tried
now it's time to move on
that's kind of where i'm at i i fall
more into the catalyst category than the
synergist but i have nothing but respect
for the synergist you guys have patience
that i just don't have
so i i don't know like the information
is out there so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]